[Música]
volvemos con un nuevo avance de noticias
en france 24 el secretario de estado de
eeuu continúa su gira por europa tras
visitar a alemania anthony blinken fue
recibido en parís por su homólogo
francés jean-yves le drían en la que es
su primera visita oficial a francia
blinken afirmó que cree que ambos países
tienen la oportunidad de demostrar que
sus democracias pueden generar
resultados reales para la población
global el jefe de la diplomacia
estadounidense se reunirá con el
presidente de manuel macrón en unas
horas discutirán entre otros temas las
relaciones con china y rúsia la lucha
contra el kobe 19 y los retos de
seguridad global blinken además expresó
su preocupación por la falta de un
acuerdo entre irán y el organismo
internacional de energía atómica la oea
que pacte un monitoreo de la actividad
nuclear en la república islámica
news
si irán continúa siendo funcionales
entre jugadoras más sofisticadas a
niveles más altos si continúa
persiguiendo otros aspectos que están
prohibidos por el acuerdo nuclear se
llegará a un punto en el que en efecto
será muy difícil regresar a los
estándares establecidos por el acuerdo
de asegurar un tiempo de espera un
tiempo que le permitiría ir a producir
cierto material para fabricar un arma
nuclear si toma esa decisión que creo
que es la urgencia de todo este esfuerzo
pero no hemos alcanzado ese punto no
puedo poner una fecha esto pero es algo
de lo que somos conscientes
y el cáncer y las labores de rescate no
se detienen en soria de florida los
equipos de emergencia tratan de
encontrar a más supervivientes tras el
derrumbe parcial de un edificio
residencial de 12 plantas en la
madrugada del jueves las autoridades
locales confirmaron que la cifra de
fallecidos aumentó a 4 mientras que hay
159 personas de las que no se sabe su
paradero lo que hace temer que el número
de muertos aumente el presidente de eeuu
joe biden
aprobó la declaración de emergencia en
el estado de florida lo que desbloquea
fondos para apoyar las labores estatales
y locales entre los desaparecidos hay al
menos 22 sudamericanos
la alcaldesa de miami del condado donde
está la localidad de share side aseguró
que están trabajando sin descanso para
rescatar a más personas y que ya cuentan
con el apoyo de todas las organizaciones
federales
vamos a seguir con toda la fuerza que
podemos que están trabajando fuerte y
también tenemos todo el apoyo de los
municipales el estado y ahora el
gobierno federal firma que aprobó el
presidente ayer y estamos aquí ya con un
representante de firma que puede
responder a sus preguntas
gracias
mientras tanto la vicepresidenta de eeuu
kamala harris visitará hoy viernes la
ciudad texana de el paso en la frontera
con méxico según la portavoz de la
vicepresidencia el objetivo del viaje de
harris a guatemala en méxico a comienzos
de junio era abordar las causas
principales de la emigración mientras
que esta visita a la frontera es para
ver los efectos de ésta y ayudará a
crear una estrategia de gobierno sobre
emigración el secretario de seguridad
nacional alejandro mayorkas la
acompañará durante la visita
y cuba podría convertirse en el primer
país latinoamericano en tener una vacuna
propia contra el kobe 19 y aprobada por
lado de ms una vez el centro para el
control estatal de medicamentos equipos
y dispositivos médicos de cuba apruebe
los candidatos vacunales abdalá y
soberana 2 que han registrado en ensayos
clínicos una eficacia del 92 y del 62
por ciento respectivamente la isla
iniciará el proceso de certificación con
la organización mundial de la salud la
ms establece que para que un candidato
vacunal sea considerado vacuna contra el
coronavirus debe demostrar una eficacia
igual o mayor al 50 por ciento un
porcentaje que ambos fármacos superan
gracias por acompañarnos volvemos en
minutos con más información